palm beach is where this Heather is
calling hey Heather how are you hi Dave
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up my husband I are taking a
Financial Peace University at Christ
Fellowship and we're in week 5 and my
husband just lost his job again ohm and
the concern is we've already gone
through all our savings the only thing
we have left is our retirement which is
about 5,000 so we don't know if we
should touch that or leave that what was
your husband making I think combined
we're making pot about 40,000 a year was
he making before he lost his job he was
making about I think 35,000 a year I say
you have a small part-time job yes and
mine job actually won't cover our
mortgage at this point sure sure okay so
he lost a $35,000 a year job and you
said again yes
so why is he losing jobs he had lost the
first job in November and it was a
permanent job and the only thing he's
been able to huh
why is he losing jobs its contract work
that he is found
so once the contract and there's no job
again ale to find okay so he hasn't
really lost the job the job just ended
yeah okay that's different than getting
fired or laid off or something else we
see that one coming now what does he do
for a living he's a computer IT person
okay and I'm guessing he's entry-level
then yes based on his income yeah cuz
top IT people make six figures and
better right correct okay all right and
so so he's just kind of helping with
installation of computers and some basic
build-out software loading that kind of
thing yes okay what
did he do before this before this he
used to do when we're in California pad
drafting for plumbing companies and when
the construction industry went down he
lost his job and we had to move the
California from Florida he went Mac for
computer certifications and started a
new field so is he still up on CAD or
was that several years ago that was
about in 2008 was the last time he's
done anything with God okay all right so
he's not up on the current versions then
that's a that's a long time ago in the
tech world especially they turn it to
you go yeah well I you know I think the
issue here is not whether to clean out
retirement the issue is he's got an
income problem in general he's on the
lower side of the income range and when
he's working and to is his work pattern
is down because he hasn't been bland
anything steady that he can count on
going forward and so really 98 percent
this discussion that's why I keep
probing around is about career follow me
because in other words I'm thinking okay
what what is it what do we need to do if
I'm him what do I need to do to be
making $75,000 a year and more steady
three years from now what are the steps
I need to take and what knowledge do I
have to get that I don't have what
connections do I get that I don't have
what what social skills have I got to
work on them where I interview better
what connection if I got to get with
people to where I can do that kind of a
thing and that's your long term goal
then you back into some short-term
intermediate goals which takes us back
to eating today which is a big goal but
how much is your mortgage payment it's a
little over twelve hundred a month okay
we just we just had it reduced it was
higher but when him and I both lost our
drops back in October in November of
last year the bank worked with us and
refinanced us and then which we were
able to do both payments but now with
him not working and I'm only at a
part-time vs. full-time like I was
before on the
as you get you just get scared out of
your mind when this stuff happens it
just take you put your stomach in your
throat it's like how are we gonna keep
the lights on how are we not going to
lose the house you know it's just
because it's it's so it's a
scorched-earth situation I mean I just
remember that so well and there's sweat
in the palm of your hands when you're
talking about it you know it just scares
the crap out of you so what would I do
if I woke up in your shoes I I would let
me just make the general statement I'm
gonna spend 98% of my time and energy
working on this career problem now let's
lay out some things that you might do
the first thing we've got to solve is
the short-term crisis the emergency that
makes you not be able to breathe and I'm
gonna do two or three things and he can
do whichever ones of these he wants to
do I don't care but if I woke up in his
shoes with what you've described to me
I'd be delivering pizzas by nightfall or
something like that because you can make
1,500 bucks a month delivering pizzas at
night five nights a week and I would me
I'd go seven nights a week because I'm
gonna get this thing behind me I'm gonna
get this mess cleaned up I'm gonna get
where I can my family can eat and it's
the kind of stuff I did when I went
broke I just did anything and everything
I could get my hands on to make money
that was legal and moral so I don't care
whether it's pizzas or what it is during
the day I'm gonna print up two types of
business cards one that says I do IT
work and I'm gonna go just business to
business to business to business and I'm
going to talk to everybody all day long
about I do IT work on a contract basis
even small business people they're so
frustrated with their computers I don't
know what to do I'm gonna be your
computer guy you call me up I just bill
out at so much an hour twenty-five bucks
an hour or fifty bucks an hour or
whatever and if you want to go ahead and
buy a block of ten hours I'll discount
it and then you're obligated to come fix
their computers for ten hours but then
you got a check for five hundred bucks
or whatever right you go into small
businesses let me tell you small
business people hate computers unless
they're in a computer business
because all of us are that are small
business people we love what computers
do and they never do it for us you know
what I'm saying yeah and so you can walk
in there there's a felt need
with a business card in his hand and
cell blocks of time or one-offs and if
the guy says I got a problem just sit
down and fix his problem right quick and
then he'll stay with you for the next
two years okay don't you know but don't
be sitting on the couch filling out
monster.com stuff looking for a Jo be
okay that's not gonna work but get out
there and hustle and grind and hand out
business cards the second thing I would
do is I jump on there and get it my
skills up on CAD and I'd go to every
plumbing and electrical company and
builder and architect and draftsman in
the whole area and I'd hand those cards
out and go hey do you need to side work
some CAD work out and I'd be doing that
after I got home for my pizza job at two
o'clock in the morning and make another
thousand or 1500 bucks a month doing
that but my day times or drumming up
business and looking for a job right
he'll work himself into a job doing that
or he'll start his own business one of
the - yeah that's what he did when they
got the first job when we moved down
here he volunteered at the hospital
doing high tea work and then they gave
him a permanent position it wasn't
permanent
okay that's not bad so you know what I'm
talking about that's what I'm gonna do
on the short term I'm gonna get the wolf
away from the door with hustle hustle
hustle hustle hustle okay then then I'm
gonna say all right what is the
recurring theme here why is it that this
stuff keeps happening to me what is
going on and it's that I have not made
myself indispensable to these companies
which has to do with his skill level and
so he's got to get his skill level up by
taking certifications and classes and
learning and growing and learning and
growing and if he has some personality
quirks or something that are holding him
back and he's the first guy he's the
last guy to get hired and the first guy
to get fired he needs to work on those I
don't know what he's doing I'm not
saying that I never met him but why you
got to sit and do a CSI on this an
autopsy and go why is it what is what is
really going on here is it skill level
is it certain level and it's probably
some of all of those things actually but
really dig in and say what have I got to
do
to move forward so he needs to read the
book linchpin by Seth Godin he needs to
become a linchpin to an organization
where he can't get fired because he's so
stinking valuable and I'll send that to
you I think I've got it I don't know if
I got it or not but if I don't have it I
won't send it but Kelly see if we've got
those in this anymore
send him a copy of start as well and
send him a copy of entree leadership I'm
gonna send you three books for him to
read and he's gonna have to read those
just in between pizza deliveries because
he's gonna have to get with him time to
hustle time to hustle this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you